Priyanka Chopra Jonas's sexy poolside
photoshoot proves Nick Jonas is total
Instagram husband gold I'm just enjoying
the ride and try to have as much fun as
possible nothing screams goddess like
the three photos Priyanka instagrammed
on Sunday from her Italian vacation the
36 year old actress can be seen showing
off her bootylicious figure in a
cream-colored one-piece bathing suit
while lounging by and in a gorgeous pool
and although the photo sesh
definitely looks professional Priyanka
revealed in the caption that it was
actually her hubby behind the camera
writing best use of a vacation the hubby
taking pictures lol at Nick Jonas
this wasn't the only time Priyanka put
Nick to work during their European get
away last week she shared this photo
also snapped by Nick with the caption
under the Tuscan Sun and if Nick's
photography skills aren't enough to get
you swooning check out this video he
posted showing the duo slow dancing
under the tuscan sunset oh look at you
expert you they also took cooking
lessons I love food that's part of the
problems I hear that you enjoy food but
the best part is Nick didn't just film
their time in the kitchen hey what's
your favorite part of making food though
[Music]
he kept Priyanka well supplied with wine
the fact that I got do it but when I
have the chef around teaching me it
feels like it can mean does it get
better than that well maybe if you're
the wife of another Joe bro
[Applause]
big brother Kevin recently gushed about
his wife Danielle instagramming this
photo of him popping the question ten
years ago and writing in part I am so
lucky to have found my best friend early
and to spend this life with you
[Music]
meanwhile middle brother Joe took a page
from Nick's book at the June premiere of
their documentary chasing happiness when
he shared this video of him snapping
pics of wife sophie turner on the red
carpet as for joe's caption premiere
carpet pro tip number one always make
sure you get the shot et chatted with
the brothers at the premiere and they
gave us all the feels when talking about
the importance of having their wives by
their sides
they're all so busy that the fact that
they actually get to come here and
support us like this means the world and
day off we don't take it sure is good to
be the wife of a joe bro
[Music]
I'm a sucker for you
[Music]